Hôm nay, cho một năm tổ bị thương của nguồn phụ trọng từ trên,
cán mộ nặng viên và nhân dân ta,
giữa máy và kính trọng của chi tội lớn,
tại năng lớn của các bạn bị năm,
nhá tư tưởng, nhá bất hóa ngon cơ li luôn của đàn.
Mọi người tự kêu việc ý, với hơn năm bị bệnh hâm tự đàn,
chừng thành qua thực hiện các mạng,
đồng chi vệ phụ trọng đã công hiện cho ở mình,
cho sự nghiệp của đàn của sinh tộc,
đồng chi là tâm buộc sáng về nhé các bạn sáng dự của một người chiến sĩ cộng sản kinh chung,
hết lắm phụ sự tộc quốc phụ phụ nhé dân.
Vềt quốc trường thành với tổ quốc,
và nhé dân đi.
Nhìn công là cũng những đặc biệt xuất sắc của cố tổng bị thương về phụ trọng,
máy máy thuộc về tổ quốc và nhé dân.
Cố tổng bị thương về phụ trọng đã để lại những dí sản,
có một chi tội lớn, tay năng lớn, nhá tư tưởng, nhá văn hóa,
bọn cơ liệu của đàn.
Sống chất ở nhìn cách của ông là cùng người đàn phíanh cộng sản kinh chung,
có viết tưởng là hạt nhân quy tụ bản kết thông nhất chỉ tự tệ của tuần đàn
tần dân, tòàn quân.
Dân như dài ở lời đều thiên liều cao viết ở nài lời như vậy,
kiên quyết chống phụ nhé cá nhân, tất cả vì sẽ nhập chung.
Nói mới là người cộng sản chứ?
Nói đi tổng về lời.
Díng cách đều sâu sắc của cố tổng bị thương về phụ trọng, không chỉ lại lời như suốt,
mà được ming trưởng bằng những việc ông làm,
bằng thế độ nhất quán của ông trong suốt cuộc đời mình ở mọi công việc,
mọi trọng chắc mà ông được cá phóng.
Nhưng người đồng chỉ, nhìn người bạn và người dân,
sẽ nhớ mải về cố tổng bị thương về phụ trọng.
Nhớ về một con người, nhìn phút quý cuộc đời về công dễn trở đất nước,
cho nhân dân, bằng một tình thần tí chiếc thêm trong sáng mạnh mẽ,
dịch lối giản gì và thiếu đồ đến tận cùng lý tổng.
Một cuộc đời trọng đẹn về ý nghĩa,
dành dự là liệu thương liên, cao quý nhất,
tên tội và sự nghiệp công lao và công dẫn,
tài năng với đức lộ của cố tổng bị thương về phụ trọng.
Sẽ còn sáng mai trong lịch sử về phán của đàn tá,
dân tật tá, trong dự chiến tính trọng của cắn bộ đàn viên và giân dân,
trong tình trà của bạn mẹ của tế.